20 de n'importe quelle nourriture
allez-y argent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons aller dans les rues jusqu'à ce que
l'État réponde à la rue ces
gars hyung dans la rue et pas dans les
États
Pavarotti dans les rues non  dans l'
état si vous voulez un gros prix,
elle n'était pas si intéressée
avanindra Marian sur votre division
se souvenant quand je dois épouser ceux
o Ginga elle est allée avec le Dendera en
retour les gens des souvenirs à la
manière sabab et ils se sont souvenus de 2008 avec
l'inflation ici  était que
les prix record du monde doublaient toutes les trois
heures au Venezuela les prix doublaient en
19 jours ici toutes les trois heures et
les gens se souviennent que cela a tout simplement détruit
toute valeur
[Musique] [Musique
] [
Musique]
[Musique]